+ 12 % de demandes en france un mois
après l'ouverture de la 28e campagne des
restos du coeur ils font face à une
situation alarmante quelle est la
situation dans les yvelines nous allons
en parler durant les prochaines minutes
avec et daniel favier bonsoir va vous
êtes le vice président des restos du
coeur donc dans le département des
yvelines quel est le premier bilan un
mois après le début de la campagne dans
le département hélas les statistiques
nationales énoncé par notre président
dans les médias nationaux se confirme
dans les yvelines nous sommes à 11 %
d'augmentation à la fois sur le nombre
de repas servis mais également sur le
nombre de personnes inscrites comptes
bénéficiaires justement viennent
aujourd'hui en restant aujourd'hui nous
avons 9380 six personnes inscrites
département des yvelines avant
département est très différent on
retrouve pas forcément le même type de
public d'une ville à une autre est ce
que cette hausse concerne l'ensemble du
département oui
malgré que les yvelines sont un
département très hétérogène en fait
puisque vire nous avons des ddc entre
ruraux descente urbain des dégradés
ville moyenne des villes importantes
donc tout ça à mélanger fait une
augmentation je dirais homogène
avec de nouveaux visages quand même même
si on sentait venir la tendance ces
nouveaux visages c'est les personnes
âgées avec des petites retraites qui ne
nous est pas venir peut-être les années
précédentes leur culture ne les a menés
pas à venir faire leur demander l'aumône
des travailleurs pauvres c'est pas
surprenant mais y en a c'est pas
surprenant parce que on connaît les
conditions économiques
du travail et tout ce que je disais
aussi la dernière fois que j'ai passé
sur votre antenne les réfugiés
politiques
économiques climatiques
là ne faisons pas assez d'études au
sujet de tous ces nombreux demandeurs
d'asile il ya un vrai problème ils sont
très nombreux donc il ya un vrai
problème qui n'est pas évidemment celui
des restos du coeur celui-ci n'est que
nous nous nous donnons leur g face et se
retrouve confronté à ces différentes
situations c'est évolué donc au cours du
temps font que les publics y évolue le
président national des restos donc
olivier berthe qui parle d' explosion
des demandes nous le mentionnions
également dans le département il dit
également que c'est du jamais vu mais
vous coûter 11 % c'est énorme
donc comment faire face nous avons des
réserves je l'avais dit aussi j'aime ans
la dernière fois suite à haut risque de
la suppression de la subvention
européenne du pead est pour l'instant
nous nous fonctionnons avec les réserves
y compris celle du pud d'ailleurs nous
avons de quoi assurer la cette campagne
d'hiver serbie a pas de rupture de stock
il nous aurons pro nous n'aurons pas de
rupture de stock mais vous savez nous
nous parlons à trois mois de délai donc
trois mois c'est rien c'est dès
maintenant qu'il faut qu'on commence à
réfléchir sérieusement à l'avenir et là
je peux pas vous dire c'est les
orientations que nous prendrons nous
allons quand même continuer à étudier
l'évolution sociologique de deux des
demandeurs et nous allons faire face à
ce qui vient de la direction
actuellement qui sont menées sur le fait
par exemple de distribuer aux
restreindre la distribution dix communes
nouvellement à certains publics pas
d'autres ça nourrit une obligation peut
être nos discussions portent
essentiellement sur l'inquiétude de
constats le repérage de la nouvelle
donne quantitative
nous allons travailler à près sur le
comment faire pour l'instant on observe
on va pas mettre en place des réponses
qui serait d adapter à une situation
observons la situation et je pense que
nous sommes assez nombreux et assez fort
et puis que nous avons beaucoup de
partenaires pour pouvoir malgré tout
répondre au moins pour cette année à la
de nombreuses demandes vous nous l'avez
dit une forte hausse + 11 % dans le
département des yvelines + 12 % au
niveau national les restos qui sont
débordées s vous êtes-vous pardon
inquiets de cette paupérisation en
france c'est la question que nous sommes
allez vous poser aujourd'hui
oui ça m'inquiète bien sûr et j'essaie
de faire en sorte
l'idée quand je peux énormément parce
que je trouve que le pouvoir d'achat je
sais pas mais je pense que il augmente
ou diminue je sais pas trop mais le
salaire ne suffit pas donc ça veut dire
que tout augmente mais du coup en fait
on vit vraiment entre parenthèses limite
entre du seuil de pauvreté parce que
vous bon on n'a pas si les moyens quoi
ça peut arriver à n'importe qui mais
même dans nos relations c'est vrai c'est
inquiétant oui bien sûr ça m'inquiète
parce que de plus en plus la vie coûte
cher et malheureusement les pauvres sont
de plus en plus pauvres les riches
deviennent de plus en plus riches a
plutôt oui oui c'est quand même alarmant
à de voir tous ces gens qui n'ont pas de
travail et surtout ces personnes âgées
qui ont du mal à finir leur vie avec une
retraite de misère
voilà ces différentes réactions qui
rejoignent ans que vous me disiez tout à
l'heure concernant les restos du coeur
aujourd'hui vous avez besoin plus que
jamais de la mobilisation des donateurs
on imagine oui mais ce que je veux bien
sûr c'est évident mais ce que je
voudrais ajouter c'est que à côté de
cette misère économique qui a été
d'ailleurs très illustré par là les
personnes vous avez interviewé il faut
les gens qui viennent nous voir ont
besoin d'autres choses aussi on ne meurt
pas de faim en france même si les restos
était pas là je pense qu'il y aurait
quand même pas beaucoup ne les restos
n'apporte pas que ça non voilà ce que je
voulais dire c'est que nous sommes là
aussi pour accompagner les gens dans
leur grande détresse qui n'est pas donc
que que alimentaire elle est au niveau
de la santé au niveau des démarches
administratives
elle est au niveau psychologique elle
est au niveau médical là aussi on n'en
parle pas beaucoup mais beaucoup de gens
vous avez bien compris s'ils n'ont pas
d'argent est soit mal y mange mal ils
sont plus malades que ceux qui se
nourrissent bien donc plus malades voyez
tout c'est un cercle vicieux tels que
nous voudrions un petit peu arrêté par
notre accompagnement donc nous ne
faisons pas que de la distribution
alimentaire est aujourd'hui avec cette
hausse des demandes aussi bien pour la
distribution alimentaire quels sont les
différents besoins est nécessaire à la
survie dont vous parliez les médicaments
par exemple les conseils l'aide les
coudes ce ne serait ce que ça est ce
qu'il y à 7 aujourd'hui oui bénévoles
oui nous en trouvons parce que justement
vous avez entendu les reportages les
gens seront sensibilisés et donc de ce
fait ils vont pas donner que de l'argent
ou que de la
2d dons en nature ils vont aussi donner
de leur temps et ils viennent nous de
nous solliciter c'est pas toujours
simple on peut pas toujours prendre tout
le monde non plus mais nous avons des
bénévoles potentiels il y en a à nous
aussi de les fidéliser après l'an
dernier 63 mille bénévoles au niveau
national dans le département des neuf
1969 c'est variable après quoi autour
des 1000 et au niveau des repas
distribués 115 millions au niveau
national pour huit cent soixante dix
mille personnes vous étiez déjà venu sur
ce plateau nous parler du pead est le
programme des deux européens qui est
fortement remis en cause des discussions
qui doivent reprendre à elles s'étaient
interrompus récemment il n'y avait pas
eu d'accord de trouver l'appel du
président au niveau national olivier
berthe c'est aussi de demander à la
france d'être sensible d'être vigilante
parce qu'il pourrait y avoir des
désaccords qui serait défavorable vous
êtes inquiet aujourd'hui sur la
suppression de cette aide qui permet
justement de meriem aussi inquiet que il
y a deux mois puisque pour l'instant il
est tout est bloqué donc il n'y a pas eu
de vote j'ai peur moi personnellement
que le temps l'usure du temps face qu on
oublie que les choses et donc ça nous
amènera sa aussi à envisager de
nouvelles manières de faire il faut se
dire aussi que de plus en plus nos
donateurs traditionnels nous allions
dans les supermarchés récupérer des
oreilles qui était à date à deux jours
de péremption ses supermarchés
maintenant ouvre des stands à bas prix
donc avec ses plus hauts récupère tous
rue marchande nous les récupérons plus
voilà aussi un autre problème qui
s'ajoute à tout le reste merci daniel
favier d'être revenu sur ce plateau vice
président des restos du coeur dans le
département des yvelines situation aussi
alarmante 1 dans le département plus de
11% sur ce premier mois de l'exercice
pour les restos à suivre le 7-8 ce sport
nouveau rendez-vous complet baume à deir
el sur tv fil 78 avec anthony rech pour
l'instant retour sur l'epic vanille
avant tout une fête religieuse nous
avons rencontré les fidèles réunis ce
dimanche en la cathédrale saint-louis à
versailles l'épiphanie c'est l'art si le
jour où les rois mages arrive à bethléem
pour adorer l'enfant nouveau-né le roi
des juifs c'est une fête importante dans
la liturgie chrétienne c'est une défaite
qui suivent la naissance du christ en ce
dimanche 6 janvier les fidèles chrétiens
de l'église saint louis de versailles
étaient venus nombreux célébrer cette
fête qui marque la manifestation du
christ dans le monde alors cette fête se
traduit aujourd'hui
d'abord une manière de manière
spectaculaire dans l'orthodoxie pour
l'orthodoxie les glisseurs de l'église
catholique la fête de l'épiphanie et la
grande fête de la nativité parce que
l'événement de la nativité ce n'est pas
que ce n'est pas pour eux d'abord que
dieu vienne dans la chair en
jésus-christ mais d'abord qu'ils soient
révélés à toutes les nations pour le
catholicisme l'épiphanie revêt la même
signification avec une messe
particulière on remarque la liturgie en
commun jours de fête c'est à dire avec
les ornements blanc des prêtres ou de
l'évêque qui célèbrera tout à l'heure ce
qui marque surtout la fête ce sont les
textes que nous choisissons trois textes
l'évangile le livre d'isaïe et les
pitres ephésiens qui s'ajoutent aux
prières lui tout au long de la messe et
si cette messe célébrer l'épiphanie
elle marquait également la veille de la
rentrée attend toujours pleins de
ferveur pour les fidèles de l'église
saint-louis venus apporter leur message
est un message qui est pas mal en ce
moment celui de la paix tout simplement